if you're a fan of stranger things
you'll recognize that this monster is a
demo Gorga but you probably never seen
one quite like this
welcome to Jeremy tell firts world where
everything can be built with balloons
you can create just about anything out
of them it's inflatable etch-a-sketch
he's made a ton of cool stuff including
a 65 foot long record-breaking balloon
dog it used eight thousand eight hundred
and sixty seven balloons and it took me
80 hours I worked 15 hour days and
another five hours on the very last day
the Guinness Book of World Records
awarded Telford's pink dog the title for
largest balloon sculpture in 2015
shattering the previous world record by
over five thousand balloons the
world-record balloon dog took me about
two weeks to plan but I did it all on
paper and well the calculator I drew it
out I had no circumference and area all
sorts of stuff in order to plan the
number of balloons I got very specific
and drawing out exactly what it was
going to look like how much time I
thought I was gonna take it took a lot
of math so if you're going to be
twisting you do need to know your math
especially geometry to twist a telford
expert level you need the right gear
this blue apron holds about a thousand
balloons but at home I have an inventory
of about half a million Globes and even
with having a half a million I typically
order more balloons every couple months
so I have balloons that are different
diameters for example this this is
called a 260 right here when you blow it
up it has about a two inch diameter this
is 160 when you blow it up you get about
a one-inch diameter I also have 350 s 3
inch diameter telephone relies on a one
step floor pump for inflation there's
hand pumps pump about 5-6 times in order
to get a balloon pump if you have a four
pump it takes one pump obviously
yourself save a little bit time if
you're one of those crazy people you can
blow with your mouth but after about
five I get a splitting headache so I
don't do that anymore and then there are
the gloves the gloves help protect my
skin because when I'm building for 10 12
hours the friction it does not love you
and the reason for the band-aids is I
need my thumb and my pointer finger to
be able to feel the balloons and stuff
while I'm building the rest of the
fingers not as much so I can keep those
covered with
with the gloves and when he needs to
take down a lot of balloons in a hurry
he reaches for what he says is the best
tool I took a weed whacker and I split
that Babylonian towel we ran out of the
thread that weed whacker uses and I
still hadn't where that dog left I was
like Oh what are we gonna do and we
finally we just let the kids come in and
they just destroyed the rest of it it
was so fun to watch Telford started
balloon sculpting in college I first got
into the balloon world when I met my
wife at a juggling Club in college her
brother taught me how to make the small
balloon animals at restaurants in order
for pay for my degree and I kind of took
that and started making a little bit
more than they were talking about but I
loved it so much that eventually started
making more record-sized stuff during
his career as a professional balloon
artist Telford sculptures have gotten
bigger and more intricate and more
creative in 2013 I changed my living
room into Bag End from The Hobbit I took
I think three days and about 2,600
balloons they had a roof had walls that
had a fireplace at a table with apples
in it had fire utensils like the poker
and the billows it was exhausting
Telford creativity doesn't stop at
sculptures either
he even builds out full-on human-sized
costumes out of nothing but balloons I
started doing balloon costumes more than
a decade ago our family celebrates
little known holidays one of the ones we
really celebrate is international Talk
Like a Pirate Day and we made it kind of
tradition to build a giant balloon
pirate costume and we build about 20 30
balloon swords and we go out and any
child that's willing to talk like a
pirate will hand them a balloon sword
has just become a fun kind of family
tradition even recreated van Gogh starry
night that one was a little bit
different because it uses mostly these
these round balloons so I took van
Gogh's Starry Night and put it on the
computer but I used Photoshop and you
can just kind of plug it out there it's
almost like working with pixels and so
you can put a dot here a dot here it
represents the balloons it was 16 feet
tall
23 feet wide I believe when it was all
done his favorite project allowed him to
build room size balloon recreations of
some of the world's great monuments
including the seven wonders of the world
he built the Statue of Zeus Great
Pyramid of Giza Colossus of Rhodes the
Coliseum the Great Wall of China the
Lighthouse of Alexandria the mausoleum
at halicarnassus the Hanging Gardens of
Babylon and a few others I gotta go
six days a week ten hours a day for
three months straight just building
these magnificent sculptures and I got
to end on my favorite one I built the
Taj Mahal and I was able to build just
all these little details into it and it
just turned out so beautifully it's
probably my favorite sculpture that I've
built
tofu runs a balloon entertainment
business in Utah and will stop at
nothing for a client I do everything
from your typical birthday party and a
lot of county and state fairs then
they'll be corporate events where I'll
do any kinds of decor like any jobs
there are mornings when I wake up and I
go I'd rather just sleep but nine times
out of ten I'm excited especially when I
get to build something large and
something new like the dimmer gorgon he
built for a Halloween party this year I
decided to build the the demagogue or
gonna screech er just it's creepy you
know I wanted something kind of creepy
somebody's coming out at you I always
try and make some sort of a movement
with the sculpture so that it feels like
it's telling a story that you look at it
you go it was doing something before you
got a frozen in a moment if you unfroze
it that would continue on doing whatever
it was doing it took Telford about six
hours and over 300 balloons to build
this seven-foot tall monster he spent a
lot of that time obsessing over the
details what I'm thinking if I could
just add a little bit more detail it
might make it that much creepier
the demography of Macy in the field kind
of sunken in kind of like it doesn't get
enough to eat so I knew I wanted to kind
of create that so I filled in thereit's
with black so it would look kind of give
the impression of shadows so you'd still
get that kind of sunken and feeling and
when it was time to build the monsters
terrifying teeth telford cut no corners
to do that he blows up one long white
balloon breaks off a section and ties it
off creating one tooth then he breaks
off a little more ties that off and
creates another tooth and so on and
that's just simply blowing up balloons
now blow him up now I pop I get about
five teeth every balloon up a pump up
I'm gonna need you know 40 50 teeth on
this thing so bring up the monotony and
I'll make 10 teeth and then add those 10
teeth to the mouth and I go back and
make another 10 teeth and add those 10
keep them out in the final few minutes
of the build
Telford adds on even more details so
I've taken these clear balloons and I'm
just kind of draping them on the
demagogue and tried to give the idea of
kind of this jewel that he has
and now we have our finished Deming
we're done it's creepy and reaching out
ready to grab yeah I've got this kind of
compulsive need to add these details the
more you can put on there more people
just go like how do you do that Atta
balloons
Telford has spent years perfecting his
technique
one thing he does is suggests the booth
of balloons by popping one end and tying
it off when you're building wind
sculptures it's hard to know exactly how
much you need to pump them up like
you're making the fingers or the toes
and you've just got way too much balloon
and there's a way you can pull the
balloon part tie the part you want you
get rid of the rest use the scraps to
tie things in later what his hands are
full tying several balloons together he
takes advantage of things like his
elbows in his chin a lot of times you're
gonna tie more than one bubble together
at once you only have two hands but you
have ton of places you can hold the boom
on your body you can hold them under
your arms your hold under your chin roll
in your elbow press the balloon against
your body it keeps them from untwisting
as you're going until you can twist it
back into itself that's one of the keys
with balloons as always has to kind of
twist back into itself or it all unravel
and a lot can go wrong one thing you get
attuned to is you can you can hear this
subtle
it's a very disheartening sound or you
hear balloons shifting on each other and
they'll make these little squeaks and
you know the only reason that they're
shifting is because something is
deflating and letting other things move
Telford has a tremendous amount of pride
in his work he plans to continue to push
the boundaries and what can be built
using only balloons for as long as he
can you will run across people that just
they just don't get it don't look at
your work and they'll be like why don't
you do something useful you know why
don't you learn accounting or why don't
you you know become an engineer and I
look at I'm gonna go you know what the
world has a lot of accountants the world
has a lot of engineers you know what
they don't have I don't have a lot of
people that can twist sculptures like
this if you take arts out of the world
if you take you know music if you take
painting and yes even if you take
balloons out of the world you can make
it less there's not going to be as as
much fun as much joy as much of that
Lindsey they're squishy shiny colorful
and they squeak and then when you can
make things out of it there's just
something magical about that